merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à monsieur Éric vert monsieur le Premier
ministre nous assistons sur la Grèce
depuis dimanche à un drôle d'exercice
d'autocélébration du président de la
République à une autosatisfaction
générale du gouvernement une sorte de
fanfare du 14 juillet vous nous aviez
dit qu'une sortie de l'euro n'aurait pas
d'incidence sur notre économie alors
qu'évidemment c'était faux que monsieur
cipras était un homme d'État alors que
Monsieur cipras ment à tout le monde
depuis le début que le couple
franco-allemand était renforcé alors
qu'il na jamais été aussi fragile
pendant longtemps le président a cherché
un rôle dans cette négociation sans le
trouver François Hollande a voulu jouer
le rôle d'entremetteur entre monsieur de
cipras et Madame Merkel ce n'est pas un
rôle digne pour la France face à cela
nos exigences ont été constantes garder
la Grèce dans la zone euro mais pas
n'importe quel prix en obtenant des
réformes profondes de l'économie grecque
et en surveillant de près leur mise en
œuvre préserver le couple allemand
franco-allemand chahuté par l'attitude
ambigue du président de la République
réformer les modes de gouvernance de la
zone euro j'ajouterai un impératif
supplémentaire celui de protéger la
France et le contribuable français alors
comme beaucoup de Français j'ai une
confiance très limitée dans votre
gouvernement et j'ai une méfiance
absolue vis-à-vis du gouvernement grec
néanmoins je voterai pour l'ouverture
des négociation car j'ai la conviction
que voter NON aurait des conséquences p
mais je souhaite avoir des réponses
précises aux questions suivantes comment
pouvez-vous nous assurer que le plan de
réforme sera strictement appliqué et
s'il ne l'était pas quelles conséquence
le Gouvernement français en tirerait-il
le piètre spectacle qui a donné l'Europe
doit trouver une réponse aussi puissante
que rapide quelles initiatives
allez-vous prendre dans ce domaine
notamment pour renforcer la zone euro
sinon cours au désastre enfin le
président de la République exige pour la
Grèce des réformes qu'il n'est pas
capable de faire en France quand
engagerez-vous en France les réme que
vous exigez pour la Grèce merci la
parole est à Monsieur le Premier
Ministre manuel
Vals monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
ministre monsieur pourrait continuer sur
le mode de l'humour en parlant des
autocélébrations j'ai comprendre que
vous gratifiez le président de votre
formation politique de l'accord qui a eu
lieu dimanche ce qui é en TER honnement
de
ratification à mon avis fait sourire et
vous inscrit j'en doute pas pour le prix
de l'humour dans quelques mois revenons
à l'essentiel ce n'est pas moi qui le
donne je vais essayer d'y participer à
ma manière revenons à l'essentiel la
France s déterminé nous sommes deux
alors Monsieur Jacob la France s
déterminée uniquement en fonction des
intérêts de l'Europe et ça a été le sens
des discussion avec Michel Sapin au
niveau de l'Eurogroupe et puis au niveau
du conseil avec le président de la
République uniquement vous-même d'autres
de vos collègues et d'ailleurs sur tous
les bancs pas tous mais une grande
majorité de ceux et de celles qui sont
ici souaitiez pas n'importe quelle
condition bien sûr que la Grèce reste
dans la zone euro pour des raisons
économique politiqu géostratégique nous
aurons l'occasion d'y revenir et chacun
souhaitait exigeait même ici il y a une
semaine que la France et l'Allemagne
avance de concert le résultat du Conseil
européen et j'aurai l'occasion de
revenir sur un certain nombre de vos
questions tout à l'heure à l'occasion du
du débat qui sera suivi d'un vote le
résultat c'est que la Grèce reste dans
la zone euro ce qui était essentiel
c'était la position de la France
défendue de la manière la plus opiniâtre
possible par le Président de la
République et enfin vous le demandiez et
c'était au cœur d'ailleurs de mon
intervention et le président dans la
République l' rappelé hier que le couple
franco-allemand joue pleinement son rôle
parce que s'il ne peut pas tout lui tout
seul dans l'Europe telle que nous la
connaissons rien ne peut se faire sans
la France et l'Allemagne qui doivent
avancer de concert et le président de la
République avait non seulement le
souci que la Grèce reste dans la zone
euro que la France et l'Allemagne le
président de la République et la
chancelière avancec
ensemble accord soit trouvé que le
contribuable français soit en effet
protégé et c'est ce résultat sur lequel
nous aurons en conscience et en
responsabilité à vous prononcer dans un
instant au cours de cet après-midi après
le débat que nous aurons alors Monsieur
ver j'aurai l'occasion de revenir sur
les questions de fond mais quand il
s'agit de l'Europe qui a traversé une
crise sans précédent cette crise l'a
fragilisé et donc il faut prendre en
effet le président de la République l'a
évoqué hier un certain nombre
d'initiatives sur la zone euro mais
quand la France joue pleinement son rôle
dans l'Europe quand le chef de l'État
joue pleinement son rôle assume et
permet grâce à l'action conjointe de la
France et de l'Allemagne à l'Europe de
sortir une crise monsieur V on oublie on
oublie à ce moment-là qu'on est un
opposant et on salue une victoire pour
l'Europe et pour la
France Merci monsieur le Premier
ministre